- [Voiceover] "Many species
have circadian rhythms
"that exhibit an
approximately 24-hour cycle.
"Circadian rhythms are
controlled by both genetics
"and environmental
conditions, including light.
"Researchers investigated
the effect of light
"on mouse behavior by
using a running wheel
"with a motion sensor to record activity
"on actograms, as shown in figure one."
All right, so let's think
about what figure one
is showing us.
We have a picture of a mouse here
that seems to be inactive,
definitely not on the running wheel,
even eyes closed, maybe it's sleeping.
And then here, a picture of a mouse
that is on the running
wheel, maybe running,
with its eyes open.
And then we see our actogram
here and it describes,
"Strategy for recording
mouse activity data.
"When a mouse is active
on the running wheel,
"the activity is recorded
as a dark horizontal line
"on an actogram.
"When the mouse is inactive,
"no dark line is recorded."
So we can see here, it gives
us the activity for each day.
So for day one, day
one is right over here.
Let me do that in a lighter color
so that I don't overwrite
what you need to see.
So day one is right over there,
and you can see from hour zero to hour 12,
since we have no black
line, the mouse is inactive.
We're not detecting activity
on the running wheel.
And then when we have the
black line from hour 12
to hour 24, that means
we are detecting activity
on the running wheel and so we can assume
that the mouse is active.
And then we have it again for day two,
and the way this is set up, it looks like
that pattern holds for every day.
Let's keep going.
"For the investigation,
"adult male mice were
individually housed in cages
"in a soundproof room
at 25 degrees Celsius."
So they wanted to make
sure that these mice
didn't bother each other,
that this was definitely
controlled conditions.
Soundproof, that they're not
impacted by outside noises,
other mice, a variation in temperature,
so they tried to for all of these things.
"Each mouse was provided
with adequate food,
"water, bedding material,
and a running wheel.
"The mice were exposed to daily periods
"of 12 hours of light,"
with the capital L,
"and 12 hours of dark,"
capital D.
L12, D12.
So that's 12 hours of
light, 12 hours of darkness,
"for 14 days, and their activity
"was continuously monitored.
"The activity data are
shown in figure two."
All right, so this is an
actogram of mouse activity
under L12, D12 conditions.
Each row represents a 24-hour period
and the dark horizontal
lines represent activity
on the running wheel,
just like we saw before.
But this is actual data
that we are recording.
So in the first 12 hours,
the mouse are in conditions
where there's light, and you
can see for the most part,
on day one, we detect no activity.
On day two, we also detective no activity.
On day three, we detect
a little bit of activity,
but for the most part, when it's light,
we detect very little to no activity.
And when it's dark, it's the opposite.
We detect a lot of activity
on that running wheel.
There's a few gaps right over here,
but for the most part, the
mouse is active when it's dark.
So the mouse is active when it's dark
and inactive
when it is light, which is the opposite
of most human beings, or frankly,
well, definitely human beings,
where we tend to be active
in the light and inactive in the dark.
Interesting.
After 14 days, so that was
just with 12 hours of light,
12 hours of darkness.
"After 14 days of L12, D12,"
so it's 12 hours of
light, 12 hours darkness,
"the mice were placed
in continuous darkness."
Capital D, capital D.
DD, that sounds unpleasant.
Continuous darkness.
And their activity on the running wheel
was reported as before.
"The activity data under
DD," continuous darkness,
"conditions are shown in figure three."
All right, so this is interesting here.
So it looks like on day one,
the mice were inactive, not 12 hours,
like we saw when we had 12 hours of light,
but it looks like about 10 hours.
And then from hour, I don't
know, this is maybe hour nine
or 10, to about hour,
it looks like maybe hour 21,
they were active.
Maybe 12 hours, maybe a
little less than 12 hours.
And then inactive,
active, inactive, active,
but it seems to be less than for 12 hours.
And then they're active
for less than 12 hours.
So you see everything shifting
up every 24-hour period
because they tend to be
inactive for less than 12 hours.
It looks like it's 10
or 11 hours each day.
And then active for a little
bit less than 12 hours.
So that's why you see
this shifting pattern
where every day the activity starts
at roughly an earlier period.
It's not a perfect trend,
but you see the trend over multiple days.
I can draw, I can show a line
that goes something like this.
You can see every day
we are starting activity
at an earlier hour.
And every day we're
also ending our activity
at an earlier hour.
And there's a lot more,
I guess you could say,
sporadic activity going on.
And remember, this under
continuous darkness.
All right, let's see if we
can answer the questions.
"The nervous system plays
a role in coordinating
"the observed activity pattern of mice
"in response to light-dark stimuli."
Yes, that makes sense, of course.
"Describe one role of each
"of the following anatomical structures
"in responding to light-dark stimuli."
A photoreceptor in the retina of an eye.
Well, this detects light.
Detects light
and sends signal.
Or maybe I'll say transmit signal.
Transmits signal
that eventually gets to brain.
That eventually
gets to brain.
Gets to the brain.
All right?
The brain.
Well, it receives signals.
It receives.
I before E, except after C.
It re-see (laughs), it receives,
it receives signals.
It receives signals and
then coordinates activity
based on that.
Coordinates activity
response based on that.
Based on signals.
Based on the signals.
So this is really just, you know,
do we know what a photoreceptor,
a brain, and a motor neuron,
I guess as related to this test.
And then a motor neuron,
well, these are neurons
that would stimulate.
You tend to think of things
that would be, you know,
like motor movement, like muscles,
but they also control things like glands.
So they stimulate
muscles, glands.
And glands could be
especially relevant here
because glands might be the things
that release or don't release hormones
that might put the mice
to sleep or wake them up.
Glands
that might release
hormones related to sleep.
Might release hormones
related to sleep, wake.
Related
to sleep
and activity.
All right, so I think that's,
we've taken a decent job
of describing the role
of each of those.
All right, let's go to part B now.
"Based on an analysis of
the data in figure two,
"describe the activity pattern of mice
"during the light and dark periods
"of the L12, D12 cycle."
Well, this was pretty straightforward.
When there was light,
so they were inactive during light.
Inactive
during light.
Active during dark.
Active
during dark.
I could've written the answer down below,
but I think I could've
squeezed this one in.
That's the basic idea.
L12, D12 cycle, we saw right over here.
Inactive during light,
and then active during the dark.
All right.
Active during the dark.
Okay.
"The researchers claim that
the genetically controlled
"circadian rhythm in
the mice does not follow
"a 24-hour cycle.
"Describe one difference
between the daily pattern
"of activity under L12, D12 conditions,
"figure two, and under,"
continuous darkness, the DD
conditions in figure three.
And "use data to support
the researchers' claim."
All right, well, we
talked about this already.
So under DD,
mice active
and inactive
for less
than 24,
or less than 12 hours each.
12 hours each.
And then we could say versus 12 hours
inactivity
under light,
under, I could say, L12.
And 12 hours activity
under D,
under D12.
So under continuous darkness,
mice active and inactive
for less than 12 hours each
versus 12 hours inactivity under L12
and to 12 hours activity under D12
when it was dark for 12 hours.
So less than
24-hour cycle.
Activity also more sporadic.
Activity
also more
sporadic.
Sporadic, or we could say less continuous.
Less continuous, there's
definitely more times
where the activity periods is broken up
by inactivity or the inactive periods
is broken up by activity.
Less continuous.
All right, I feel pretty good about that.
Now, let's see.
Actually, since I'm already
at 11 minutes in this video,
I'll continue the next two
parts in the next video.